Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est jeudi et vous le savez maintenant, le jeudi je vous parle un peu de ce que j'ai envie.
Ca n'a pas forcément un lien direct avec le mentalisme, mais en fait on retrouve toujours un petit peu l'idée.
La semaine dernière, je vous ai parlé de 2 jeux que j'aimais beaucoup.
Cette semaine je reste dans le même état d'esprit.
Je vais vous parler de 2 livres, 2 livres qui m'ont beaucoup plu.
Encore une fois, je précise c'est pas du placement de produit, ce sont vraiment des livres qui m'ont interpellés, je les ai achetés je les ai lus.
Le premier c'est le "Dictionnaire de l'impossible" de Didier Van... euh...
Je n'arrive pas à savoir comment on prononce ce nom !
Didier Van Cauwelaert.
Didier, on va l'appeler Didier
Effectivement c'est monté comme un dictionnaire c'est-à-dire que tout est dans l'ordre alphabétique tous les thèmes,
et il prend des expériences soit scientifiques, soit non rationnelles.
Et il en parle en fait, il raconte ce qu'il s'est passé à chaque fois.
Ca peut aller d'histoires qui ont été racontées, alors après on valide ou on valide pas sur la combustion humaine, sur la combustion spontanée,
comme sur des choses qui ont été validées, avec de vrais protocoles scientifiques qui visaient à voir si les poussins avaient des pouvoirs psy.
Vous n'entendrez plus jamais "piou-piou" de la même manière !
Pour chacune des situations qu'il relate il y a les sources évidemment, et puis elles prennent à chaque fois entre 2 et 10 pages
donc ça se lit rapidement ça peut se lire dans les transports, on peut lire juste 1 ou 2 par jour.
Je vous avoue que je l'ai dévoré !
Voilà, c'est le "Dictionnaire de l'impossible".
Du coup ça fait quelque chose d'assez léger à lire sur des sujets qui sont plus passionnants les uns que les autres et puis après on peut aller s'amuser à fouiller sur le net.
C'est ce que j'ai fais moi et j'ai appris pas mal de choses en fait, c'est surtout l'histoire des poussins en fait qui attirait les robots par leur pensée
qu'est assez.... assez étrange, assez marrante.
Pour vous dire rapidement le protocole en fait, il y avait un robot que les poussins prenaient pour leur mère puisque depuis la naissance ils l'avaient.
Et le robot avait des mouvements aléatoires de programmés, et on sait que les poussins qui piaillaient devant la vitre essayaient d'attirer le robot vers eux.
Mais le robot n'a pas de sens par rapport à ça, c'était complètement aléatoire et pourtant mathématiquement ils ont battus le hasard sur le fait
que le robot se rapproche toujours des poussins.
Je ne vous raconte pas la suite parce que c'est très intéressant et je vous laisserai le découvrir ou regarder même juste sur internet l'histoire des poussins avec les robots.
On trouve des sources.
Et le deuxième, c'est un livre que j'ai lu très récemment, c'est "Petites expériences extra sensorielles" de Richard Wiseman c'est aux éditions Dunod.
Des éditions que je ne connaissais pas non plus !
Alors là c'est très intéressant parce que déjà c'est écrit d'une manière très fun, c'est très rigolo à lire, l'angle c'est vraiment un ton léger, quasi humoristique,
et il prend des thèmes comme le contrôle mental, parler avec les morts, sortir de son corps...
Et à chaque fois ça se décompose de la manière suivante :
Il va parler d'histoires, qui sont célèbres ou pas mais qui ont été racontées, dans des livres, sur des phénomènes comme ça étranges et paranormaux.
Et ensuite il y apporte un point de vue scientifique, donc les contre-arguments scientifiques mais il n'y a pas de parti pris.
C'est-à-dire que, il détruit pas les croyances des gens si vous avez des croyances dans des domaines, il n'est pas là pour les détruire mais il apporte aussi des 2 regards:
Le regard extra-sensoriel, le regard scientifique et dedans, c'est ça qui m'a beaucoup plu,
il propose des expériences, des choses assez ludiques que vous pourrez faire vous mêmes, pour vivre les sensations de ces expériences extra-sensorielles.
Il y a par exemple 2 expériences pour vivre, des sensations de sortie hors du corps, de décorporation donc, où vous allez tromper votre esprit.
En fait c'est tout un procédé qui permet de tromper son esprit et de faire croire à sa tête qu'on est ailleurs.
C'est à chaque fois très facile à faire, il y en a une où il faut juste une serviette et un livre et l'autre il faut deux miroirs.
C'était assez étrange de voir à quel point on pouvait le tromper aussi dans sa perception de l'espace en fait.
De faire croire à notre esprit que notre corps c'est celui qu'on voit devant nous.
Ca parle aussi de magiciens, ça parle de mentalisme, ça parle de psychologie.
Son vrai angle caché, c'est les incroyables pouvoirs qu'a notre cerveau en fait, et comment on s'auto-trompe aussi parfois nous-mêmes.
Et peut-être que c'est pour ça que des fois on a des croyances un peu particulières ou pas !
Encore une fois il y a pas de parti pris, le traitement est super fun et super rigolo.
Voilà c'est la vidéo du jeudi !
Elle est un petit peu plus rapide elle un petit peu plus fun !
La semaine prochaine je ne vous parlerai pas de choses que j'ai vues, lues ou pas d'objets en tout cas.
Mais d'un autre sujet probablement en rapport avec les mathématiques, juste des trucs un petit peu ouf qu'on sait pas toujours.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu n'oubliez pas de la partager.
Abonnez vous à la chaîne c'est très important.
Vous pouvez aussi venir me voir sur les Hallucinations Collectives que vous êtes en train de voir actuellement
ou samedi soir, samedi soir je serai dans le sud, je serai à la Vallette du Var en spectacle.
Vous pouvez réserver, je crois qu'il reste encore quelques places.
Objectif 2500 abonnés. A 2500 abonnés je fais un live où vous serez en direct avec moi on pourra discuter faire des trucs de mentalisme ensemble.
D'ici là rendez-vous demain à 17H sur cette chaîne YouTube pour le prochain Mental Vlog !
Ciao !